the Joe Rogan experience that brings us
back to the idea of meaning and
universal basic income I think the idea
of giving someone $15,000 a year doesn't
necessarily cause whatever whatever one
would worry about is Pele being on the
dole you would have a bunch of listless
people out there with no meaning in life
but the idea is that $15,000 a year and
I'm not necessarily sure I agree with
this I'm not even forcing this but that
$15,000 a year we just provide you with
the necessities to get by in life it
would give you food it would give you
shelter well that's not going to stop at
15 because the moment people like I mean
a 15 like their people died and more but
Sanders would be on the sixteen
companies are too big yeah that case it
doesn't it doesn't stop it just it just
goes all the way to bankruptcy the
concern is to slide to socialism it's
obvious yeah I mean heck if I was on if
I was not working and I was getting my
15 a year I would happily vote for the
guy who would give me 20 or 25 it's just
common sense what do you say to the
people that don't believe that there is
such a thing of ethical as ethical or
compassionate capitalism and there's
many people today that are espousing
Marxism and their spouse in some sort of
a socialist society where they believe
that capitalism has screwed people over
and eliminated the middle class and
there are absolutely problems with
capitalism I think monopolies are a
problem I think that crony capitalism is
a problem with the government you know
kind of gets in bed with them and sort
of forces things I think the bankers
have really you know raped society and
the rest of us are suffering literally
yeah they've essentially taking huge
risks where they privatize the gains and
the socialize the losses so when it
fails they basically get bailed out and
bankrupt everybody else so capitalism
has gotten a really bad name let's talk
about his free exchange free markets
free markets and free exchange are
intrinsic to humans from when the first
person started a fire and somebody came
along with a deer and said hey if I cook
my dear and your fire I'll share some of
it with you right so specialization of
Labor we trade that's built into the
human species basic math comes from
accounting keeping
tract of debts and credits and so on we
need to be able to engage in free trade
the correct criticism of capitalism is
when it does not provide equal
opportunity and so we should always
strive to provide equal opportunity but
people confuse that with equal outcome
when you have equal outcome that can
only be enforced through violence
because different people free people
make different choices and when they
make different choices they have
different outcomes and if you don't let
them suffer the consequences of bad
choices or reap the rewards from good
choices then you are forcibly
redistributing through violence it's
interesting that there isn't there are
no socialists working socialists
examples that exist without violence you
basically need someone to show up with a
gun and say ok you're not allowed to do
that you hand this over to that person
so one of the reasons why did this
podcast is because I believe everybody
can be wealthy everybody it's not a
zero-sum game it is a positive sum game
you create something brand new you
exchange it with me for something brand
new I've created there's higher utility
for both of us
the sum of the value created is positive
it's not like status where it's like
you're higher up I'm lower down you're
president so I must be vice president
you're a plus one I'm a minus one it has
to cancel a zero we should all be all
for playing positive some ethical games
the problem is because of these looters
who have ruined capitalism's name but
then you get socialists coming in and
saying burn the whole system down right
you burn the whole system down we end up
like Venezuela or the former Soviet
Union you know you don't want to be a
fail socialist states with emaciated
teens hunting cats in the streets to eat
right that's literally what happens in
some of these places so I think it's
very important not to destroy the engine
of progress that brought us here yet the
idea that socialism just hasn't worked
yet that it needs to the didn't we just
need to do it right if we do it right we
can net you if you ever 100 hundred
million dead and yeah yeah well let's
keep trying all over the world yeah and
in every single time it's implemented D
have you ever had a conversation with
someone who's a socialist who many times
some of my better better friends are
socialist really we'd really get into it
yeah and what is their I mean does
anyone have a compelling perspective at
all I I think really socialism comes
from the heart right you all we all want
to be so
list capitalism comes from the head
because they're always cheaters in any
system yes and there's incentives in any
system so when you're young if you're if
you're not a socialist you have no heart
when you're older if you're not a
capitalist you have no head right you
haven't thought it through so I
understand where it comes from I always
like Nassim Taleb spray become this
where he said with my family I am a
communist with my close friends I am a
socialist you know at my state level
politics I'm a Democrat at you know
higher levels I'm a Republican and at
the federal level I'm a libertarian
right so basically the larger the group
of people you have mashed together who
have different interests the less trust
there is the more cheating there is the
better the incentives have to be aligned
the better the system has to work the
more you're towards capitalism the
smaller the group you're in you're in a
kibbutz you're in your commie and you're
in your house you're in your tribe by
all means be a socialist with my aunts
with my brother with my cousins and my
uncle's with my mom yes family I'm a
socialist that's the right way to live a
loving happy integrated life yes but
when you're dealing with strangers I
mean you want to be a real socialist
great open all your doors and windows
tomorrow please everybody come take what
you want see how that works out yeah
this idea of income inequality that
always strikes me as a very it's a
deceptive term income inequality well
let's flip it around
it comes from outcome inequality yeah
and the outcome inequality is there
because you made different choices now
again going back if it was because you
don't have the same opportunities that's
a problem yes so society should always
try to give people equal opportunities
so for example instead of basic income
what if we had a retraining program
built into our basic social fabric which
said that every four years or every six
years or whatever it is maybe it's every
ten you can take one year out and we'll
pay for you to go retrain completely and
you can go into any profession you like
that has some earning power and output
hopefully a creative long term
profession and you can re-educate
yourself that would be much better for
society on all levels than basically
just saying now you're gonna be the dole
for the rest of your life
yeah just you would have to lead that
horse to water and then make him drink
it requires people to put in some effort
yes you know we can't all just sit
around it's just not well that's my
perspective on income inequality there's
always effort inequality and and thought
inequality there's just some people that
are obsessed and if those people become
successful it doesn't mean they stole
from you
it just means that they put in the
amount of energy and effort that was
required to reach where they're at and
there's a lot of riches signaling that
goes on now people say well it's because
you're privileged you know what the
greatest privileges you're alive from
85% of humanity is dead yeah so how
privileged are you then you're living in
the first world and you're you know you
have four limbs etc so you can take that
argument all the way it's kind of a
nonsense discussion
[Applause]